[Musique]
avoir des enfants
que se passe-t-il le nours pas trop ça
gazouille ce soir que veux tu dire
une couture
[Musique]
bonne anniversaire
ma poupée joli mais oui ma chère c'est
un fait aujourd'hui
d'arabe et nouvelle tout en organdi
il est bien ben avec des broderies
tu n'as pas changé
tu es toujours je lis depuis que jeter
notre essor
jeunes est bien soigné j'ai eu du souci
j'en aurais sans doute
accord
bon anniversaire
ma poupée chérie je suis très fier de te
voir aujourd'hui
avec tes dents elle tue alerte mais oui
d'une demoiselle à la mode de paris
turf répond quand tu as envie
de te promener au jardin
et je dis non
un défendue si tu va bouder dans son
coin
mais je te pardonne ce que tu me fais au
polissonne je t'aime et tu le sais bon
anniversaire
mon gentille amour
ta petite merde
aimera toujours
[Musique]
elle en a de la chance cette demoiselle
caprices on lui fait souvent son
anniversaire oui à la même femme wac
apprécié si pape rhône elle s'occupait
pas tout le temps dehors c'est vrai à
moi on ne me le souhaitent qu'une fois
par an mon anniversaire
mon pauvre petit on n'est jamais bien
légal sur moi et je fais des bâtons moi
aussi je
[Musique]
fis nous nous taisons 6e propre
malheureux en huit manches
sega vient ma chérie on va faire dodo
bonne nuit les petits
ils ont l'air bons ces biscuits
[Musique]
nous bons amis leur frère fabrice mai
oui mon petit nid calme à vos nuits
maman papa rebelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon anniversaire petit caprice on s'en
va à trop en route la nuit les enfants
du patro sait bien qu on l'a dit werfel
mais oui nounours et je te gars très
chic l'ont fait pour eux
[Musique]
à